Donald Trump has announced that
sanctions are being imposed on the
International Criminal Court it's being
alleged that the institution violates
the sovereignty of the United States
Trump administration is taking the
following actions
first we're authorizing the imposition
of economic sanctions against ICC
officials directly engaged in ICC
efforts to investigate US personnel or
allied personnel against that allied
state's consent and against others who
material of support such officials
activities instead of having the
International Criminal Court monitor
Human Rights around the world it seems
that the United States government will
take on this task all for its own Mike
Pompeo the US Secretary of State
recently came out with a report
describing religious freedom around the
world and he touted the United States as
the ideal in the speech Mike Pompeo
trotted out the old image of an
exceptional United States that stands
above all others when it comes to
liberty and freedom our nation is so
special it's the greatest nation in the
history of civilization it's so special
that challenges like the ones that we
are confronting here in the United
States today will be managed head-on
there will be a political process that's
engaged if they'll be wide open debate
and our our core principles the the fact
that we respect every human being
because they are made in the image of
God will be reflected in the way that
the United States responds to these
challenges according to Mike Pompeo
American discourse is free and open it's
only in other countries apparently that
mass protests are taking place
[Music]
[Applause]
apparently it's only in other countries
that peaceful protests are dispersed
with tear gas and dissidents are
arrested and held without charges only
in foreign lands does the political
elite ignore the needs of the people and
plow ahead building a police state no
not in America only six years ago
Congress was overwhelming with pro
police militarization nancy pelosi eliot
engel and over 350 lawmakers of both
parties joined together to vote against
representative Grayson's amendment to
end transfers of military equipment to
local police in 2014 and of course
America always respects the rights of
journalists and freedom of the press we
have received numerous reports of
journalists attacked harassed arrested
and detained in the course of their work
government protests in the United States
against systemic racism and police
brutality only in other lands do allies
watch in horror at the Miss handling of
protests we all watch in horror and
consternation what's going on in the
United States
only in foreign lands do we see citizens
begging the United Nations to speak up
for their rights the undersigned family
members of victims of police killings
and civil society organizations from
around the world call on member states
of the UN Human Rights Council to
urgently convene a special session on
the situation of human rights in the
United States in order to respond to the
unfolding grave human rights crisis born
out of the repression of nationwide
protests you see the United States is
exceptional it's got a perfect record it
does not need an International Criminal
Court and it's got solid ground to stand
on and criticize other countries yeah
well these days even many staunch US
allies might strongly disagree with that
Kalib Maupin RT New York
you